hello everyone a while back and that
would be november of 2021 i had the
distinct pleasure of having a discussion
with dr richard dawkins who apart from
being an esteemed evolutionary biologist
and theorist is also one of the world's
foremost atheists
we danced back and forth for quite a
while on gmail before agreeing to meet
and our meeting i think was really
productive
so
i have a recording of it audio only as
was the agreement and it starts rather
abruptly as we entered right into a
discussion and ends abruptly in a sense
too because we ran out of our time
without running out of topics and so i
walked over to aha as it turned out a
chapel on the oxford campus and that
wasn't the place that dr dawkins wanted
to go with me so that's where it ended
in any case we had a wide-ranging
conversation i found him charming and
erudite and intelligent and a man of
good will and i really enjoyed the
conversation so i hope you enjoy it too
and i hope that there's more of it
because we have a lot more to talk about
i i feel that way and i think perhaps he
did by the end of our conversation
so enjoy
[Music]
almost a hundred percent of the
conversations that i have with people on
the street are
very very positive
i would say it's one in five thousand
that isn't yes
but
he's only a sex one
yes and there's no shortage of yeah
trouble what's the motivation of the of
the few who are hostile
that's a good question isn't it
because you could think about that as
sort of a general metaphysical question
you know what's the motivation of the
few who are truly hostile
i think often they have me confused with
a figment of their imagination sure you
know so
when i
you you sent me one of your papers on uh
biological sex
well
stating what you stated in that paper is
already enough in the current world to
make you
very unpopular with with a certain class
of people regardless of why you think
what you think or what your reasons are
um
when i
when all this first exploded around me
i had released a couple of youtube
videos
three of them i think decrying
a bill c-16 that was passed by the
canadian parliament which mandated
pronoun use
and for me it had nothing to do with the
transgender issue or maybe it did
peripherally as a political issue you
know and and maybe as a psychological
issue because
the transgender issue is very
complicated if you're a
psychopathologist
but for me it was just compelled speech
it's like i don't care what your reason
is
i am not saying
the words i am legally obligated to say
and the case i made on youtube was
well first the american supreme court
had made compelled voluntary speech they
declared it unconstitutional in 1942
and second there was never a common law
jurisdiction
in the entire world that ever compelled
speech for any reason is canada the only
country that does that that does this
that's a good question um
i don't know i know
the united states doesn't yes we've also
had this encounter this proliferation of
these
so-called human rights commissions which
are
like a quasi-judicial inquisition system
that have been taken over completely by
the woke types and so
there was a restaurant in vancouver
quite recently where the man who owned
it although he seemed to have done
backflips to satisfy this angry
hypothetically transgender individual
he'd employed he was fined something
like 35 000 and forced to take this you
know these mandatory sensitivity
training programs is this in canada
that's in canada vancouver's major city
on the west coast
and so you know i was assured when i
voiced my opposition
and i said well this is illegal and said
well nothing will happen if you don't
comply and i thought well the hell with
that well what do you mean nothing will
happen and it's illegal yes quite no
nothing will yeah so how can how and how
can you possibly say nothing will happen
but that wasn't the point for me either
well i made these videos at the same
time i made a video
because the university of toronto was
implementing
mandatory
racial sensitivity training
and i know the literature pertaining to
the implicit association test let's say
which is the test that all these
half-wit hr types use to diagnose your
implicit bias and then
they want to train you with explicit
training techniques to reduce your bias
which can't work if their theory is
correct because it takes mass practice
to change or eliminate implicit bias and
then there's no evidence whatsoever that
the training programs work and some
evidence that they're actually
counterproductive
and the implicit
association test which is essentially
used as a diagnostic instrument
has neither the predictive validity nor
the test retest reliability to be used
in an ethical manner as a diagnostic
test which i also said in these videos
and so
that caused a lot of trouble and i
didn't really expect it you know i mean
well why should you it's perfectly
reasonable i just want to say i admire
your
courage in speaking out about this
because
a huge number of people including me
um
totally agree with you and many many of
them are just too frightened to say so
because they have been intimidated
there's there's massive intimidation
going on
especially in the academic world
yeah
and you're one of the few people who's
actually stood up to this intimidation
and i wish to salute you well thanks for
that that's very much appreciated well i
understand
because i've studied it a lot why people
are intimidated
you know i've talked to conservative
politicians all over canada and the
united states although i also talk to
particularly in the states moderate
democrat types a lot
but the conservatives
uh especially in canada they're
absolutely terrified that if they
make any conservative pronouncements
that they'll be singled out and mobbed
and it's unbelievably unpleasant i mean
not to mention potentially dangerous i
mean
i was
careful in what i did
see i'd worked as a clinician for 20
years and i help people negotiate
unbelievably stressful situations you
know where their careers were on the
line where their families were on the
line their sanity was on the line
and i got very good at
figuring out how to step through such
minefields you know strategically and
carefully and so by the time i
said something
i had three sources of independent
income so i had a clinical practice
and i had a company that was generating
a certain amount of money and i had my
university position
and so i didn't think that you know i
was fairly well insulated i thought
because when i said i wouldn't do this i
meant there is no bloody way you're
going to make me do this no matter what
you do and i thought that through all
the way to the bottom you know could
lose my job yeah i can live with that
could lose my clinical practice
yeah i could live with that
what about jail well probably won't come
to that but
put me in jail and see what happens
and so
i meant no
and i meant no more than they meant yes
and that's part of the reason it caused
such a stir i would say
um
so but
many of the clients i dealt with you
know they'd be under pressure to conform
ideologically in the workplace
and be pressured badly and you know they
had families to support mortgages pay
and
it was
i wouldn't say easier for them exactly
to
go along you know step by step or even
microstep by microstep than to stand up
and risk being taken out
and so if i was in my clinical practice
if someone needed to stand up in the
workplace
to a bullying boss say or to an
ideological
cadre which was very frequently the case
in the corporate world
we'd get their
cv or resume in order and
make sure it was polished up and if they
had any educational
faults that needed to be rectified to
make them marketable we'd address that
and then they'd apply for different jobs
and they'd go on a few interviews so
they were ready and then then they could
go in and we did that often too when i
was helping people negotiate for a raise
it's like
get yourself ready you know
so you can go in there and tell your
boss why you're valuable or you can go
in there and tell your boss why they
better get the hell off your case or
they're either gonna lose you or there's
gonna be trouble but man you have to
prepare for that
and so you see in the academia and in
the corporate workplace
and in the entertainment industry now
which is absolutely corrupted by this
sort of thing
300 000 micro retreats
and here we are
so what's a micro retreat
okay
so i'm sitting in a faculty meeting at
the university of toronto
and the administration announces that
they're going to
increase the size of our fourth year
seminars by
a factor of two
we don't have enough faculty we actually
don't have enough money to hire more
faculty well that's because you spent
all the money on administrators over the
last 20 years and here's the data that
pertain to that but that's beside the
point so would it be okay if you just
you know had twice as many people in
your fourth year seminar well that's a
crowning seminar for the students and a
seminar with 40 people in it isn't a
seminar it's another class yeah
and so i tell my faculty
conference
why don't you just say no
like no
we're not doing this
well
we won't get what we want
well you may have noticed that when
you've been dealing with the
administration for the last 20 years
they make all sorts of plans and often
you're consulted and then none of the
plans come to fruition and then they
implement something that has nothing to
do with you want with what you want all
the time and all of you know that
because it's happened to you yeah well
you know
we have to go along with them
okay
well so then what happened you know what
happened i don't know if it happened
here
at oxford but in north american
universities
the administrative
load
like a parasite load
and i think the biological metaphor is
exactly app by the way
exploded over the last 40 years
universities have eaten up 70 cents of
every dollar that the american federal
government pumped into student aid it's
almost all gone into the hands of
administrators the faculty numbers
haven't grown in a commensurate manner
with the student numbers and so the
administration took over
well and then because they were composed
of the same sort of people
that the faculty were who did all these
micro retreats when the diversity equity
and inclusivity people started to invade
the administration they just did the
same thing and so
here we are
well i think we agree about this so we
get on to whatever it says you want to
talk about today yes yes yes well i'd
like to talk to you about your paper the
the one you sent me about
the organism as a model yes okay yeah um
if you don't mind because i'd like to i
guess what i was curious about because i
i didn't find anything in that paper
that i disagreed with at all i thought
yeah that's and i know a little bit
about the engineering literature that
suggests that and even the computational
literature that suggests that in some
sense
an organism that operates within the
world has to be a model of that world
yes in order for it to be
in order for it to be operated in the
world yes and then you detailed out all
sorts of real world examples including
well let's say stick insects where
you know not only are they a model of
the world but they look just like the
world yes and animals in winter versus
summer changing their coats and birds of
course you said you could derive the
structure of the atmosphere and probably
the earth grab the gravitational field
and probably the strength of the
gravitational field by a sufficiently
detailed analysis of the bird very good
i hadn't noticed that one that's very
good yeah oh well you did mention you
did mention the the the air aspect with
birds anyways but but i'm sure you could
i'm sure you could generalize that
yes well good i'm glad you like that um
it's it's a book i'm now working on
called the genetic book of the dead
um which um
is all about the idea that that the
animal is a model of not the present but
the past
ancestral worlds yes because the animals
genes have been filtered through
a long series of
environments
so the genome is a palimpsest of
ancient
environments more recent more recent
more recently still very
very recent including
extremely recent and then we go out of
the genome and and the nervous system
becomes part of the palimpsest recent
experience right so you could say that
so and correct me correct me if i ever
put words in your mouth because i want
to get what you think yes exactly right
um
the genetic code is a repository of
information that generates
every perhaps ever more complex or ever
more fine-grained
not try to say that
all i wanted to say is that is that the
genetic code
is a d
in principle decodable description of
ancient of ancient environments right
right okay
fair enough so so the question then i
suppose would be
at what level of resolution
right yes so there's this idea i think i
mentioned in my talk the other day i
really like this idea and
when i talk about religious matters by
the way i i try to speak metaphorically
and psychologically and to tread on
ground that might be theological
only when that's absolutely necessary
and never if i can possibly manage it so
i like to think about things in
psychological and and biological terms
and physical terms for that matter
wherever possible it keeps things
clearer and simpler
and so but there is this idea
um in relationship to the idea of the
incarnation that
christ
could embody god
through a process of kenosis and and the
the scholastic theoreticians who made
this case because they were trying to
account for how
the entire cosmos you might say could
fit in one body
and the idea was well
there was an emptying of god and when i
was reading that in relationship to
heuristic processing
and also to the idea of
of low resolution representations in in
computational simulation and in
relationship to this idea that
an animal has to be the model of the
world i thought well
you kind of you want to also be an
unbiased model of the world right so
if you make a thumbnail this is a good
way of thinking about it i think a
computer thumbnail
is a good
model of
uh
essentially a two-dimensional slice of
the world right so it's a low resolution
image
and
if it's an
the interesting thing about a low
resolution image is that it's an
unbiased sample of the
color space of the
of the image right it's not it doesn't
have an ideological bent
part of the reason it's an accurate
representation is and this has to do
with that idea of redundancy that you
developed in your paper
so
if i took a picture of that wall which
is basically white the picture is going
to be white it's not going to be as
varied in its whiteness as the actual
wall but it's going to be an unbiased
random essentially random sample of the
whiteness of that wall and so it can
stand in for it in a manner that's
unbiased and a lot of
i think our internal representations are
i like to use the the terminology low
resolution because it's it implies this
it is also associated in some sense with
the idea of a compression algorithm in
computation because what a compression
algorithm does is it reduces redundancy
and all that's stored
as information is the non-redundant
information
and you can usually take something quite
complex and if it has regularities in it
as you pointed out in the paper then you
can
you can abstract the regularities
and just represent them and it's
interesting it's really interesting
actually because
with some compression algorithms
some
get rid of data but some
and they don't compress quite as tightly
some allow you to recreate the entire
original from the compression because
there is genuine redundancy in the in
the external world
so
the kenosis idea part of the reason i'm
interested in this and
i was extremely interested in the fact
that when we first had our emails
back and forth before we decided to meet
i
suggested that we meet and that i would
like that and
you sent me an email and you said i
suspect you want to talk about this
and i thought it was remarkable to me
that you picked that particular
paragraph because that was exactly why i
wanted to talk to you and it was i think
probably the most clearly i'd ever
stated that particular idea and so that
was quite
i forgotten what that was well
it has to do with what we're talking
about to some degree
the question is if the
human
being is a model of the environment
what exactly is being modeled so because
you might ask well what exactly is the
environment
and so and that's where
i think we could have a very fruitful
exchange of views
now that
the
the thick insect
has obviously
been shaped to a massive degree by
natural selection because it looks like
a stick
but
i'm very curious about the role of
sexual selection
because that makes things weirdly
complicated especially among human
beings because
first of all sexual selection can result
in runaway
processes like i think i might have read
this in your book the irish elk story
yes
yes yeah so so and some people have
suggested maybe it was you because i
read your books
it was a long time ago but you know they
stuck
many people have suggested that at least
one of the mechanisms that drove our
rapid cortical evolution was stringent
sexual selection
primarily applied by females to males i
think that might be geoffrey miller who
suggested that okay
and and so
what do you
what
if sexual selection is one of the
processes that really drove our
rapid divergence away from our
chimpanzee human shared relative
then
part of what we modeled as a consequence
of that sexual selection is whatever
women wanted
and so then the question is
what exactly is it that's driving human
female
sexual selection
and that's really what i wanted to talk
to you about because
that would be incorporated in us as a
model
you know if women are looking for a kind
of ideal let's say in a mate
then as they exercise their hypergamous
choice
the male is going to come to ever more
closely approximate that ideal whatever
it is and that's going to be an implicit
ideal because none of that's conscious
obviously yes
it seems to me you keep wandering from
one subject to another without sticking
to
to one at a time i mean we came we went
to kenosis and
i kind of wonder what that's got to do
with anything and then it's it's
probably some difference in our thinking
style you know i think
well
one of the
would you say you're more interested in
ideas or aesthetics
ideas okay that's what i would have
guessed yes
i'm probably
more somewhat more interested in
aesthetics although it's close
and part of
the way that would be reflected in our
thinking styles is that i would think in
a more in a style that has a more loose
associational structure
that's right i mean let me take one
example of something that i've seen of
yours
um which is it's not nothing with sexual
selection um
you you once uh showed in a lecture a
picture of
snakes spiraling around each other oh
yes
and and you said something like
i think it's positively you know that
that is the representation of dna yes we
could let's leave that one but i promise
i i promise i will return to that well
let there's a rough time because that
that seems to me to go to the heart
of what may be a difference between us
this aesthetic i mean that that that
idea that that in some sense represents
dna to me to be complete nonsense okay i
will i will absolutely address that okay
god
well this is something i did want to
talk to you about okay it does take us
rather far down the rabbit hole though i
would be i would say okay
well i think it may be fundamental to
our difference that's fine that's fine
i'm more than happy to address it and
people have called me out on that a lot
you know
i actually
threw that in a lecture because i was
thinking in a loosely associative way
about some very complicated things and i
was struck by this
this uh recurrence of the
the double helix pattern yes and
cultural representations all over the
place you love symbols i mean you're
obsessed with symbols yes um
you're almost drunk on symbols and you
could say that uh uh
um i think you've got to stop and say
what does it actually mean
to say absolutely and and the snakes
trining is one thing there are others
but that would be a very good one to try
to nail down yeah well you know part of
the we could talk about technically for
a moment you know because i think it is
a difference in thinking style and i
think one of the reasons that your
writing is so appealing to people
including me
is that your language is very precise
it's very obvious what you mean when you
say a given word you know and
some of the psychologists that i've
really admired like jeffrey gray who
wrote a great book on the
neuropsychology of anxiety like if
you're interested in the idea of
modeling
that that's i think that's the most
profound
neuroscience text that's ever been
written i haven't read that i confess i
used to know jeffrey gray but i haven't
read it
it's
it's a great book yes and it integrates
cybernetic theory and animal
experimental work and neurophysiology
and and the function of emotion like
it's a really good book and it it does
it is centrally concerned with the idea
of modeling because
because gray worked see in your paper
and i'll get to the dna thing i promise
you okay in your paper you talk about
the response of a single cell to the
repeated to a repeated identical
stimulus
okay
sokolov who was one of the
great russian neuropsychologists
identified
the orienting reflex as the
manifestation of the habituation
uh the habituation
phenomenon at the highest level of
nervous system organization so for
example
if i put headphones on you
and then i hook you to a galvanometer
and i play say i play a middle c at
exactly the same volume one second apart
40 times okay so what will happen is
when you first hear it
there'll be a change in skin response
and then the second time you hear it a
slightly smaller change until
it will habituate completely zero
response but then if you change the
volume or the pitch or the space between
the
tones or interestingly enough
if you skip a tone where the tone should
have been
and there's silence lovely you'll get an
orange i like that great okay
now out of that the russians
hypothesized
that
you build an internal model which is
exactly what you say in that paper and
then your nervous system
searches for deviations from the model
and so and then your consciousness is
oriented towards the deviation and it's
oriented by
a deep instinct like literally an
instinct so for example if you're
walking down the road
you have a map of the environment
imagine that there's a loud clattering
noise behind you
you'll stop and this is all involuntary
it's it's driven by
extremely low level nervous system
mechanism
so you orient towards the place of
maximal novelty
and then you do rapid visual exploration
to try to
rehabituate yourself to the environment
and then if it's you know a tradesman's
truck bumped
you map that onto regularities you
already know
and you continue onward but
all of that's mediated by emotion so
anxieties
literally we wrote a paper on this
was one of the papers i'm most happy
with
that anxiety
signifies the emergence of entropy
that's what it does so you can map
anxiety right down to well you can write
map it right down to the to the level of
entropy yes so so anyways gray also
mapped the emotions
neuropharmacologically and
neurophysiologically onto the orienting
reflex and then he identified the brain
areas so the hippocampus the hippocampus
is
extremely metabolically active
it's extremely expensive to operate
psychophysiologically it's very
susceptible to oxygen deprivation and
brain damage
the hippocampus moves information from
short-term
attention to long-term memory
and it's crucially involved in
the
the analysis and inhibition of that
orienting response and you could also
think too that
this movement of orientation
in some sense your whole brain is set up
to inhibit that
and so so here's an interesting
corollary of that one of the things that
psychedelics seem to do
is to disinhibit you called it lateral
inhibition there's also a phenomenon
called latent inhibition which is the
inhibiting
effect of the memory of the regularities
on your current perception and so when
you look at the world mostly what you
see is memory and that's been tracked in
the visual system so you know there are
these visual primitives like line
detection
but if you look at the layers of the
visual system and you look at the bottom
layer where the retinal cells first make
contact with the visual cortex there are
more top down inputs from the cortex
into that low level than there are
retinal inputs
so even at the level of initial
detection most of what you see is memory
and that memory inhibits the novelty
response and the novelty response this
is part of the reason i got interested
in mystical experience
the novelty response is twofold it's not
just anxiety
it's also exploratory curiosity
and that's because when there's
something novel
well you have to be careful because
god only knows what it might be like it
might be the thing that kills you might
be nothing
so anxiety freezes you
but the hypothalamus which is sits right
on top of the spinal cord and is the
highest
integrating center of the instinctual
responses of the motor system it's way
pre-cortical it's divided into two parts
and one part of it governs
the dopaminergic system that
that mediates
incentive reward so all positive emotion
but more importantly active exploration
and so what happens if you hit something
that's
novel in relationship to
the notions of preconceived regularities
positive emotion is disinhibited
that's exploration
and negative emotion is disinhibited
simultaneously and there's a man named
rudolf otto who wrote a book
called oh i can't remember the name of
the book but
it's not varieties of religious
experience because that's uh james
anyways he described the primordial
act of perception as numinous
mysterium tremendous
and it's a combination of positive and
negative emotion
and i thought
that's
that's
pre-latent inhibition perception
psychedelics disinhibit
latent inhibition of perception
and that's why they produce a mystical
experience
but the mystical experience i mean
there's three aspects to it let's say
there's an overwhelming positive emotion
simultaneously there's overwhelming
negative emotion so and that's like uh
an awe experience
and then there's the disinhibition of
fantasy simultaneously which is
something like the attempt to map that
and so people find that well absolutely
overwhelming but by definition you know
it
yes
it is overwhelming literally now you
might say
so i'm going to answer that
snake question that's what i'm trying to
do you know
i studied
one symbol
which is was the scandinavian world tree
symbol and so the scandinavians thought
that there was a tree at the center of
the cosmos they called that igdrasil and
on the outside of the tree there's a
snake that eats its own tail
now the sh
the the amazonian
jungle dwellers who
discovered
ayahuasca
have the same image it's exactly the
same it's a tree at the center of the
cosmos with a snake that eats its own
tail
now ayahuasca is a
very bizarre chemical and no one has any
idea how the natives
synthesized it
to iowa ayahuasca is a combination of
dmt which is an extremely powerful
hallucinogenic
that only lasts 10 minutes
and a monoamine oxidase inhibitor
which makes the dmt experience last
eight hours because
monoamine oxidase inhibitors stop the
breakdown of dmt
which is a monoamine
the amazonians had to find these two
plants that were widely separated
geographically
out of like hundreds of thousands of
plants
and they had to mix them together and
they had to boil them properly for a
certain amount of time to make ayahuasca
well they've been using ayahuasca
probably for
like 15 000 years
now
the scandinavians didn't use ayahuasca
the ones who came up with the world
trade thousand years
for 15 000 years yeah
in in
in amazonia
in the jungles well they got there about
15 000 years ago
now maybe you know we don't know how
long it took them to discover it but you
know in in most of those relatively
primordial and small tribal groups
the
the pattern is
unbroken oral tradition like they're not
transformative societies
they do pretty much what their ancestors
did okay so once you have a phenomenon
which is something in common between
scandinavian
and uh
amazonia yes so do you have an
explanation for that
yes i mean is well i would say the
expertise you're talking archetypes now
well
we won't get to that yet because like i
said
and i'm sure you would appreciate this
we want to keep things as
much on the ground as possible yes yes
okay well so
it's not unreasonable to note that
a particular chemical might have the
same effect on widely distributed people
right so okay so you'd expect constancy
of response to a pharmacological agent
rather than variants yes and that's even
true with the psychedelics and
psilocybin for example
most almost all the psychedelics have a
very similar chemical structure
it's a peculiar ring structure but but
it's similar to lsd
psilocybin dmt the classic hallucinogens
psilocybin tends to produce a type of
vision that has a fair bit of
commonality across cultures and you can
think about that as well it's the
psychophysiological effect of the drug
now it's weird because
it has this emotional effect
and this disinhibition of emotion can go
two ways because people have heavenly
experiences say that's almost complete
disinhibition of positive emotion or
they can have bad trips that's hell
essentially that's complete
disinhibition of negative emotion and a
lot of that seems to depend on the
context within which they have the
experience so if there's a lot of
negative things happening
in that context that can be magnified by
the experience and things can go like
horribly sideways that accounted for a
lot of what happened
badly in the psychedelic explosion in
the u.s in the 60s and that was
precipitated by the discovery of lsd and
also
there was a man a mycologist who was a
banker
who went into mexico and found a woman
practicing shaman who used psilocybin
mushrooms and she agreed to let them try
them and that was one of the
soma he wrote soma very famous book on
amanita muscaria i can't remember
his name at the moment wausau that was
wausau he was the first person he
introduced psilocybins and psilocybin
mushrooms into western culture and like
we weren't ready for any of that and
certainly were ready for lsd these are
unbelievably powerful pharmacological
lsd i think is the most psychoactive
chemical ever found by an order of
magnitude it just takes a few million
molecules to produce an intense
psychedelic experience
in any case
sorry this is complicated
the ancient
scandinavians
either used
amanita muscaria those are red mushrooms
with the white dots that you see in
fairy tales all the time same
color as santa claus and
and his flying reindeer
and reindeer like amanita muscaria
mushrooms by the way
so and sort of flies even weirdly enough
but i think the scandinavians also used
psilocybin now the question is what the
hell's that tree
if you take it seriously and should take
it seriously i mean
these images were used for a very very
long time and people thought about them
very hard
so imagine that
well there first of all you could
imagine that the tree has this resonance
as a sacred
item partly because we've had a
relationship with trees for maybe 60
million years
you know we our ancestors lived in trees
for a long time and you know you hear
these psychologists talk about
the african veldt as our
like uber environment you know that
we're adapted to it's like well it kind
of depends on your time frame
you know that's
five million years
trees that's like 50 million years
so the notion of the tree that's
that's in there
and
all of our cathedrals have a tree-like
architecture and that the light through
the
stained glass windows that's
sunlight through the glass there are
trees all over the world
too yes surprising that they would come
into people's hearts and symbolism yes
but but there's a conceptual reason see
because
i think and this is speculation i know
it's speculation i understand this
perfectly well
it's clear that our consciousness can
move up and down levels of analysis to
some degree
and levels of nervous system
creation and repair
so imagine when you're writing
you can attend to a letter or a word or
phrase or a sentence or a
paragraph or you can move your
level of apprehension up and down
from the micro level to the more macro
level
and you know at the highest level of
your consciousness you can apprehend the
most general ideas at this lowest level
very specific
well actually very specific motor
movements
so if you're typing a word
and you make a mistake
you don't fix it conceptually
you move your finger and fix it
and so that's kind of where it grounds
out and so
our consciousness sort of grounds out at
the bodily level
at the level of adjustable voluntarily
adjustable micromusculature and then at
the high level at the highest level of
abstract concept so it can move this
consciousness
well
the world tree is a vision of the
microcosm to the macrocosm the tree is
used as a metaphor for that and so a
proto-scientific idea intuition of the
idea that
there's a
there's a kind of dimension
that
constitutes
zooming in on things right to the
smallest possible level of apprehension
and zooming out to the most general
level of apprehension dust particles to
cosmos let's say
well psychedelics seem to expand that
capacity
so that consciousness can move up and
down layers of apprehension that aren't
available to consciousness under its
normal conditions
and
there there are good accounts of
shamanic experiences they're very
strange they're very well documented
the shamanic experience involves a death
and then
past the death the capacity to move up
and down this microcosmic to macrocosmic
realm in a way that doesn't seem
possible under conditions of normal
consciousness
and so we're raveling around again
um
well the question is
how far down the levels of analysis can
consciousness go under extreme
conditions
and so and i said this was speculation
but i've seen these dual
they're often dual entwined serpents
they're very common in fact i have one
made by an indian carver canadian native
carver in maya it's so cool
it's called a sea soodle i have it up in
my third floor it's set on two totem
poles there's a man in the middle
there's a serpent on both side of him
and i asked him what this
image meant to his people because he's
still part of an unbroken tradition
he said they had a myth that
something alien landed on the earth it
was this seasonal object and that when
it was rolling down the mountain that it
landed on it took the form of all the
things that it encountered
and so
well like i said this is in the realm of
wild speculation but i know what crick
thought about the origin of dna
well he thought he thought it was too
complex to have evolved oh obviously
what do you mean you mean the idea of it
coming from from elsewhere now i mean i
know that's an infinite regression okay
that's what was okay so that was all
that was behind that you know bit of
speculation which i normally would do
these coiling surfaces i think that
under some conditions people can
vision can expand to the point where
they can see down into the micro level
they can apprehend the micro level
consciously
you think that our consciousness can
extend down to the micro level to the
level i do micro the micro micro micro
level of
dna okay well since we're on this topic
i have taken extremely high doses of
psilocybin
like four doses is enough basically to
knock you out of your body
i wouldn't recommend it casually
i took seven grams three times
and i had this shamanic experience it
was unbelievable and i don't even know
how i have no idea how to make sense
well i believe that i could quite
understand you have a most extraordinary
experience i've never taken such a drug
but i could imagine the most remarkable
experience but you've just said
that you think that your consciousness
can see into your cells
and see
this the structure of dna that has got
to be utter nonsense i'm sorry well it
like i said i i'm perfectly reasonable
willing to admit forthrightly that that
is a highly speculative idea
well it is speculative but it's also got
to be false why
right no no and ferret look
in all probability you're right
right i mean
we both
wise enough to use occam's razor
right
and so
and i said that
it's funny that that particular
statement got picked up because i think
that was the most
what would you say
secular intuit speculative idea that i'd
ever uttered to my students yes well
fair enough i mean i i understand that
and so
it's strange to be in a position to
defend it i'm telling you why i was why
i made that but there was more to it
than that you know because in this
visionary experience
i could feel my consciousness go down
these levels of analysis
and i could see things that
they appeared to me in my field of
imagination
and i looked at them and i thought
that looks a lot like dna but you're an
educated man who already knows about dna
yes these people didn't know what people
do about it that's what's so no they
didn't know it doesn't surprise me in
the least that you could have a
visionary experience and think you see
your dna in your cells that of course is
highly plausible well
because i already know about it yes what
is not plausible is it somebody who does
not know about it an an ancient chinese
sculptor whatever it was yes who who
working long before watson and [ __ ]
discovered the structure of dna could
possibly apprehend possibly
that just isn't fair enough
and
um i guess i would only say in in in
defense of that idea is that
it is the case that consciousness can
travel up and down levels of analysis in
a
sense
it
real
inconceivable that that's not an
expandable capacity under some
circumstances
you know because you've got to ask
yourself like
i do yoga in the morning
a kundalini yoga exercise and
i i've done it for about 20 years
and i learned a long while back that
when yogis are practicing their asanas
these positions that's not yoga
they practice the asanas because they're
postures that stretch you
and then once they get to master them
they basically do an exploration of
their body for places of discomfort and
use the asanas to
heal
and you might say well what do you mean
heal and well my experience is that if i
move my head for example
down like this i can i'll have a pain
manifest itself in my back where i'm
tight and then i can pay attention to
that
and loosen the musculature
and then
the pain will disappear and as i've been
recovering from my last illness i've
been doing this quite a bit because my
body is full of knots and pain of all
sorts and i can explore them
and
do something with them
and
i actually think we can also do that to
each other to some degree we do that
massage therapists are very good at that
i think it's part of an elaborated
grooming knowledge but what that means
is that internally at least whatever my
consciousness is can apprehend these
places of
trouble that are physiological yes and
that i can explore them and the question
is well
how deep first of all what is that
exploration that's the past
how far down can you go that is
perfectly plausible yes i i i wouldn't
object to that also i i wouldn't wish to
pin you down on on what was a sort of
throwaway speculation on the dna but it
does seem to me that that's
kind of representative of what i mean by
being drunk on symbols yes um it's it's
um
well
you are
rightly
hostile to post-modernism
and i'm not hostile to
the post-modernist claim that there's
that there's a terrible problem
that arises when you understand that
there's an indefinite number of
interpretations of things yes they got
that right but what i'm really hostile
to is the answer okay then that i think
that's okay look i want to put you i've
got one of my
books here
um
now i've talked too much during this
discussion so far
there's something i really want to ask
you about if you don't mind well yes
before before yes i just really just
pursue this okay
okay i can i can read this out okay okay
we're on audio sure
um
this is one one of my it's my only
written attack on postmodernism
um and
um uh
this is
uh
from laka
um
who says
um
by calculating that signification
according to the algebraic method used
here namely s
capital s signify of a little less
signified equals little s the statement
with s equals minus one produces a
square root of minus one
la con then goes on to conclude that the
erectile organ
the the penis
is equivalent to the square root of
minus one of the signification produced
above of the juices that it restores by
the coefficient of its statement to the
function of lack of signifier minus one
then another quote from
a feminist
thinker well this is actually an
interpreter of her
her
expositor catherine hales talking about
why
fluid mechanics
is um
difficult to understand
and she says
the privilege of solid over fluid
mechanics and indeed the inability of
science to deal with the turbulent flow
at all
she attributes to the association of
fluidity with femininity
whereas men have sex organs that
protrude and become rigid women have
have openings that lack that sort of
leak menstrual blood and vaginal fluids
from this perspective it is no wonder
that science has not been able to arrive
at a successful model for turbulence the
problem of turbulent flow cannot be
solved because the conception of fluids
and of women have been formulated so as
necessary to to leave unarticulated
remainders so okay okay so i'm going to
play devil's
symbolism okay so let's let's take that
apart two ways okay okay the first is
let's deal with laka okay okay laka is a
fraud as far as i'm glad you say that
well i have tried to read lecon yeah and
i cannot make heads or tails of him good
and
it may be because i'm stupid
it's not i don't think so now
people have accused jung of the same
sort of mysticism that lacan engages in
but i can understand young i don't think
he's a mystic at all
what jung was doing is very complicated
and it maps very nicely on to
evolutionary biology
of all the french intellectuals that
i've read i think lacan is the most
fraudulent okay okay so we'll just put
him aside and you know i haven't read
that much lacan partly because i can't
now i've read a lot of foucault and i'm
rereading the order of things and the
order of things i would say if if you're
writing a book about modeling as well as
reading the neuropsychology of anxiety
the order of things is very much worth
reading okay and he doesn't wander off
into ideological i've only found that he
made one mistake in the first half of
the book
because
foucault is a social constructionist to
a large degree but he does talk about
its categories of the imagination that's
not exactly the phrase he uses but he
does make reference at one point to the
fact that our conceptual structures are
grounded in an underlying
imagination which to me is a nod to
biology and so but i like the order of
things i i read it a long time ago i'm
just rereading it now
um
so forget about lacan yeah
the feminist now
i'm going to argue from the perspective
of a biologist
here i would say
i'm going to give the devil her due in
this case
there are
we do have a proclivity to map
sexual relationship onto the world
and the degree for obvious reasons
because we have to perceive sexual
relationship at a very deep level we do
have a tendency to animate things or to
perceive them as if they're animated
and the degree to which those a priory
perceptual proclivities
might bias
what would otherwise be objective
thinking is open for valid discussion
now that doesn't mean that
look
my daughter last night was engaged in
the debate at the oxford union and that
i i was there you were there yeah yeah
well you heard
carol yeah
well that was
a mind-boggling
performance as far as i was concerned it
was exactly the example of the sort of
thing that you're tossing out it was
absolutely beyond comprehension i was so
happy to be there because i thought i
had never heard all of that
expressed and simultaneously invalidated
so effectively but you know
the side she argued for won by the vote
i didn't know who what which side won
the decide the
that we should move beyond me yes and
now independent of the merits of the
underlying argument except for carols
the fact that that feminist scholar who
attributed meat eating to white
supremacist patriarchal oppression yeah
that argument was so appalling
was that the was that the final one
right right at the end oh you missed it
yeah oh that's too bad it's too bad you
really needed to be left for that i left
we we we left when the president
said a student should start talking
so
you must have you must have left just
before that happened yes
so tell me then oh my god it was just
well that that was essentially it that
was her argument that
meat eating
was a
consequence of the imposition of a
patriarchal racist
oppressive okay
white supremacist narrative on
essentially a feminine background yeah
it's the same thing okay well um now
you're saying i
you're saying
that you don't know how much of that
character is is my thinking despite my
opposition to post-modernism that's
right yes absolutely yeah well that's a
you know that's that's a that's a an
absolutely reasonable question and
given that doubt which i can certainly
understand why you would hold it's
perfectly reasonable of you and i think
perspicacious to have pointed to my
attempt to
speculate about how these images of
intertwined helixes happen to propagate
themselves all over the world because
i have a pro see i have a problem with
that because i can't understand why
that's the case
so for example
there's a really interesting chinese
image which is one of the ones that i
referred to in that particular lecture
that shows
i hope i can remember this exactly right
so it's this intertwined underlying
serpentine structure giving rise to a
female and male form yes and it's
portrayed that way in the cosmogonic
myth that yeah these forms emerge out of
this underlying helical structure and
but there are stories like that
everywhere and so you might say well
it's a case of false pattern recognition
and that's really a problem right that's
the problem of misperception okay now
wait i i i have no problem with
um
my big problem is equating it with with
dna
yes that's [ __ ] however yes
however what might be what might be
interesting would be a
a commonality
between myths all around the world
and then um
anthropologists uh have
argue about whether this is because of
cross-infection of ideas or whether
there's something jungian about about
the um and i think that's a genuinely
interesting
question question yes um and most of the
affective neuroscientists that i've met
the good ones are tilted pretty hard
towards
the biological primitive argument yes
forms of perception well color is one of
them well i think that's interesting and
of course
the the coincidence of an image or a
statue in this part of the world in that
part of the world
you should think about how
improbable it is that two people might
have hit upon the same
uh the same design i mean the idea of
right
as snakes spiraling around each other
it's not that difficult to think of it
it's not it wouldn't be
ridiculously improbable that two people
two tribes and opposite sides of the
world would independently
come upon that um no no and and it might
not point to anything
particular
except that it is the use of snakes i i
would say though you know the idea of
that coiled snake or the dual coil snake
is also a powerful
symbol of healing
and so yes that's partly why it's used
as a symbol for physicians yes exactly
and so and there is the idea that's part
and parcel of that and this would be
let's say separate from the dna idea
and then snakes shed their skin
and they're reborn and so that's part of
the reason why they're symbols of
transformation exactly and and that
notion of death and regeneration is
obviously central to the idea of healing
and so that's another explanation for
the use of the snake okay so i'm
interested in in the improbability of
coincidence in this case now if you say
um
uh people in in scandinavia and people
in the amazonian jungle had
independently developed an alphabet
which was the same alphabet now that
would be impressive i mean that would
right well yes yes well but but but it's
also equally impressive that separated
people did develop alphabets yeah but
not the same no i know they didn't use
but but there's a level at which it's
the same right because they are
alphabetic and they are the use of
written forms to represent sounds well
it's that's a sensible thing to have and
i mean it it is such a good idea that
wouldn't be
improbable that
two tribes would have the same idea
that's true but well but it gets
complicated too well it gets complicated
in the context of this argument because
one of the debates that foucault had
that was famous was a debate with
chomsky yes and foucault of course is a
radical social constructionist except
when he isn't now and then right and and
i'm not being smart about that the order
of things is quite a careful book
but chomsky was laying out a more
archetypal argument in some sense and
chomsky thinks that there is something
like an underlying language grammar and
so the fact that
an alphabetic structure might be
discovered by two separate peoples would
be partly a reflective underlying
biological commonality and so it is very
difficult to draw a border between these
and i would also say i agree with you
completely that
associative thinking of the kind that
you just read to me can go far astray
what that is is false pattern
recognition you know so it's
it's the app perception or perhaps the
projection of a pattern onto a
background let's say an underlying
reality that actually isn't
characterized by that pattern but but
that's actually part of the dilemma of
thought though too isn't it because like
i think thought
is usefully parceled out into a
revelatory element and a
dialogical element
and so the revelatory element is
while you're sitting there and thoughts
enter the theater of your imagination
and so it's in a sense
phenomenologically like they sort of
spring
up from the void
and you can be struck by a thought which
is really interesting right it's like i
agree it's your thought why are you
struck by it where does it come from yes
that's it no kidding where does it come
from but then there's another element
which is
well not all intuitions are valid
the things that strike you even though
being struck is often a pretty good
indication that there's something there
but it's not always an indication and
there are certain forms of
psychopathology schizophrenia in
particular
schizophrenia is characterized by the
misfiring of that intuition system so
for example partly what happens to
people who have
um
like ideas of reference
they'll be watching television
and the latent inhibition will get
stripped away from their perception of
the voices
and so now the voices become magnified
in significance
and to account for the magnification of
emotional significance they start
thinking
the television has a special message for
me
it's like the reset receipt of a
religious revelation and it's often
accompanied by religious ideation so
it's not that uncommon although it's
somewhat uncommon for people who are
flooredly schizophrenic to identify with
christmas very light religious
revelation it is very it is it is very
likely i wanted to come to because
because you you characterize yourself as
religious sometimes and yet you don't
seem to believe in a supernatural
creator not the people that you do or
not all the time i know they do when
whenever i believe in god and i say well
i act as though god exists yes but which
is a reference to this mortal idea
last night you you seem to be well let
you come to the idea of truth you seem
to be saying that
that which is beneficial to humanity or
to the or your reduce your anxiety or
makes you feel good or reduces stress
is true
no no no it's more
it's more than that and good i'm glad
that we're on to this part of this
discussion
um
when darwin first published his
biological treaties
the origin of species
the new england pragmatists got a hold
of his manuscript william james and c.s
purse
and william james founded
experimental psychology and cs purse was
probably the most profound philosopher
the americans ever produced
and they had a club the psychological
the phyllis
the i think it was the psychological
club it was either that or the
philosophical club but i believe it was
a psychological club
and they believed that
darwin's theorizing required
a new epistemology it was so
revolutionary and they
purse in particular develop pragmatism
and pragmatism is like an engineering
truth claim and i don't think you can be
an evolutionary biologist without being
a pragmatist i don't think it's possible
i don't think it's coherent conceptually
and so purse was trying to
solve the problem of
well
how can something be true when for
fundamentally ignorant about everything
in the final analysis
and the answer was
well we have truths that are true enough
and you might say well what do you mean
true enough and the answer would be
they're true enough to be used as tools
to achieve a certain end in a certain
space over a certain time period
and so your truth is true enough if it
gets you from point a to b when you're
using it the tool is adequate for the
job if it performs the task intended and
for purse and the
pragmatists
that was it
there was no true superordinate to that
now it's complicated because
some pragmatic truths
are functional across broader spans of
time and space than others so they're
more like ultimate truths but
this was not a grounding of truth in a
newtonian idea or cartesian idea or even
in a
idea of objective truth
because they derived their concept of
truth from their analysis of the
evolutionary process and they said and
so what i really want to know what you
think about this it's like
say there's truth in the human form i'll
speak metaphorically
but biologically that truth only
suffices for like 90 years
right we're good enough we're good
enough as a model
it may be that uh
our knowledge of truth is is incomplete
and and
we can never be sure of anything but
that doesn't mean there isn't truth out
there well
truth is a slippery concept because it
can be used very many ways and i'm not
trying to i believe me i'm not trying to
bandy words about
i do not believe that the newtonian
conception of truth and the evolutionary
conception of truth are commensurate
and i think the evolutionary
because well it's tough right because
you might think
well when you're talking about truth are
you talking about the nature of ultimate
reality or are you talking about the
relationship of your models to that
reality
i don't know that i care too much about
that because i
i mean let me tell you something that is
true
okay um we are uh
just we are
cousins of chimpanzees yes um that is
objectively true um it's it's another
thing that's true is that the earth
orbits the sun yes these are these are
not
um
what one can argue about the
epistemology of that
but i
um
want to be
a realist about this and and say that
that that there may be
kinds of truth which are somehow
filtered through our darwinian past and
which
um
influence the way we see truth and we
may be deceived by all sorts of things
we may be self-deceived
but
there are objective truths it is the
business of science to find them and
science has tools
for
stripping off
subjective bias for stripping off
self-deception yes and and that that's
why we do double-blind trials absolutely
that's why we use random assignations as
well yeah absolutely okay
right
and who can argue with the power of the
scientific process and but i would also
say that the religious people that
you've debated
they lose before
they open their mouths because they
don't notice
that you impose this realist metaphysics
on the argument before it starts
now i'm not saying that you're not
justified in doing that i'm not i'm not
saying that because that's open to
question but i am saying they don't
notice that that's what's happened but
there's a problem here it's a real
problem
and this is the postmodern conundrum i
would say
there
are it's useful
and true to say that there are objective
facts but the problem is
there's an infinite number of them
true okay so now the question is
as a scientist
how do you decide which facts to attend
to
and the answer to that is you cannot do
that
using the scientific process no that's
true okay so okay so then the question
is
look
i've done a lot of statistical analysis
of data sets in my time you know and
when i was a naive undergraduate and i'm
not particularly mathematically gifted
by the way statistics was quite a slog
for me until i started to understand it
conceptually and then i started to enjoy
it but i kind of imagined that
the data contained the information
the statistical process was an algorithm
to reduce the data to the information
and it was kind of a mechanistic process
i didn't realize at all that a data set
is
you know imagine i've had data sets that
had you know
5 000 participants and 200 rules of rows
of variables it's like there's a lot of
information in that data set
and so then the question is
how the hell do you derive a valid
conclusion from that plethora of
information
because you could report all sorts of
meaningless correlations right they
would be spurious
but also
practically useless and there's just
endless numbers of those in the data set
you know
how do you judiciously use a statistical
process to extract out
the information that that is what true
yes but it's not just true you want it
to be useful
i agree yes right okay and so that's
where the pragmatism issue comes in
right because
then we might say
and one of the reasons i wanted to talk
to you is because i know you care deeply
about truth and i know that you're
motivated by it
and so then i would say that that
that's a metaphysical relationship in
some sense it's an a prior metaphysical
relationship because
you made a commitment
to truth
and i would also say that that's an act
of faith because you might ask yourself
in science
is it truth or untruth that serves the
world
well uh that's where we came back that's
where we came in because um there are
all sorts of truths which do not serve
the world there are all sorts of truths
which are very unpleasant
yes you get an
analogy might be uh
as a doctor um you you um have a patient
who has incurable cancer
and you have to decide whether to tell
that patient the truth or not right well
um you could debate this with your
colleagues you might um your colleagues
might say well he's better off not
telling him he's better not not knowing
so the truth in this case is not
beneficial
what would you pick what would you well
would you want to know that's irrelevant
no no no i would rock i would i would
one and i would want to know okay well
but
i agree that there are dangerous truths
let's say and there are truths that
under some circumstances
might be harmful and that could be used
as weapons but i would still say
i don't believe that you can be a
scientist and
discover objective truth say in a useful
manner
without being
committed
to a metaphysical
vision of the redeeming power of the
truth
because i don't even think you can make
the micro decisions that you're making
while you're reading a book and sifting
through it right trying to separate the
wheat from the chaff without
i don't want to impose this view on this
conversation right i'm trying to explore
it because
it's i'm very i've dealt with plenty of
bad scientists in my time
you know psychology is rife with what
they call p hacking where you just run
repeated correlations until you find one
that yeah oh that that's bad science yes
um but it's also bad but it's bad ethics
it's like well why not look why not do
that if it advances your career yes i'm
quite i mean that that's bad and that's
not i think what we're talking about i i
thought you were saying that
truth is
that which is beneficial in my in my in
my analogy when you're arguing with your
colleagues whether to tell this patient
the truth
you could very well argue shall we tell
him or shall we not it would be
beneficial not to or beneficial to but
everybody should agree that it is true
that this man has cancer
that is true yes yes well this is partly
why this this
issue is so
unbelievably complicated because
what you just said is true
but it's also the case that
you have to apply an ethical framework
onto that
infinity of
in order to focus on and communicate
those see you've picked topics that you
communicate to people
and there are other topics you didn't
pick yes and there's a lot most of the
other topics you didn't pick
and so the question to me is and this is
partly why i got interested in jung by
the way because he was very interested
in the unconscious direction of
attention the psychoanalysts were
fascinated by that that's partly why
they're interested in freudian slips but
you
okay one thing we could ask do you think
that you picked your field of study or
did it pick you
uh i
i'm not sure um but i don't think that's
not relevant it doesn't it well it is no
but it is it has to be relevant because
it's actually the question of relevance
and so there's a whole branch of
cognitive science now uh i'd like to
have you talk to this colleague of mine
named john verveiki john vervicky is
unbelievably smart and the problem he's
spent his whole career focusing on is
how in the world do you decide
what you attend to when there's an
almost infinite number of things to
attend that's a big question it's a huge
question it's a question that applies to
science when you decide what to what to
work on as you say there's an
infinite number of things you could
attend to work on and you choose some of
them and that's a decision which people
take and that biases your view of the
world and everything but nevertheless
there is objective truth it doesn't
affect the fact that subjective truth
the the the mere fact there's a
very large number of
things you could attend to and you have
to choose one of them
doesn't affect
the fact that that there are lots of
truths out there and
right but it definitely it yes
but it definitely does affect the way
that science is con see this is also why
the postmodern critics have been so
effective in what they've done
it's because they're they're pushing the
notion
that a narrative necessarily drives the
process of inquiry even in relationship
to objective facts and i think that's
true
and that that's partly what we're
discussing now i also think and i don't
know how to reconcile these things like
the fact that you're making a case for
the existence of the objective fact it's
like i'm not going to argue about that
that doesn't mean i understand it fully
because i can't quite understand the
relationship between the objective fact
and the necessity for utility and partly
i can't understand that on biological
grounds
you know because are fundamentally when
you look at things
i would say that the description of
truth that you're
purveying in right now in this argument
i'm not trying to make it any more
general than that
is not one that's well nested inside the
epistemology that you would derive from
evolutionary biology because you would
you would you would say
in some sense that were tilted in a very
fundamental manner
to
only apprehend those things that will
aid survival and reproduction
and so to hell with the objective facts
well that's probably true that that our
sense organs and
our bias towards that which helps
helps us to survive and our internal
sense also to speak our attention
mechanisms inside the our thought our
thought mechanisms so we we are
creatures who evolved on the african
savannah and from forests earlier on
and our
ability to understand the world let
alone what we attend to is limited by
that we are blinkered by the fact that
that that our
um bodies and our brains were designed
to survive in africa well that's what
that feminist critic was pointing to in
a very well
let's look in an awkward and tendentious
manner and an overstated manner
absolutely not as bad as lacal right
well then then with well
we are living with i don't understand
quantum theory and the reason i don't
understand quantum theory from yes
evolutionary point of view is that it's
not evolving it doesn't map onto our
bodies exactly and i don't
um so
there are i what i think is remarkable
actually that there are people who
understand quantum theory i agree i mean
that that
and that's well that also points to to
to your point that also points to our
capacity to apprehend truths that in
some sense appear to be outside the pure
confines of the evolutionary struggle
yes but then that's also a
problem in some ways for evolutionary
theory i mean you can you know
wave that off as a spandrel but i think
that's a big mistake when
when we're talking about something as
profound as the capacity to understand
says
why should you be so presumptuous as to
think you can understand all these
things when you're only an animal which
is which has evolved to survive and
reproduce right but what but the thing
that's so horrible about that in some
sense is that's also at the core of the
post-modern critique of science that
claim now
the human humanities types when they
make a claim like that often sound like
the woman that you just described but
you know i try to give the devil as do
and i'm trying to do that with
post-modernism because you know i i
think the conclusions that were drawn
from the post-modernist canon you know
the fundamental conclusion as far as i'm
concerned
of the the french postmodernist
process allied with a certain kind of
marxism is that
the entire process of categorization all
our categories plus the process of
categorization
are attributable
to
the expression of will to power that's
it
oppression tyranny dominance and there's
actually
i would say that the evolutionary
biologists are in part responsible for
that weirdly enough i am not trying to
throw stones you know i'm
like to think of myself to the degree
that i can manage it as an evolutionary
psychologist i accept the tenets of
evolutionary biology i don't think you
can understand anything about biology
without doing that
but
here's the argument from the biological
perspective
we ratchet ourselves up hierarchies of
power
to attain positions of status
particularly as males to give us
preferential access to mating resources
and that contaminates everything we do
it's like
hey
now
i want to ask you one final question i
know we're running out of time but i
don't i don't care i want to ask you
this question okay
i talked to sam harris i've talked to
sam harris five times
and the first time i talked to him i was
extremely ill
and we got bogged down in a discussion
of truth
pragmatism versus objective something
we've been banning that back and forth
and it's a tough it's a tough nut to
crack
and then we had four
more discussions that were all public
and there was a tremendous amount of
interest in them which was quite
stunning it was staggering we had 10 000
people at in dublin to one and about the
same to the o in london and we were
discussing issues just like this you
know
and
i made some mistakes dealing with sam
because i had a
point i wanted to make you know and it
was i suppose the point of this
pragmatism in some sense in its
relationship to evolutionary biology and
so i was trying to sort of win the
argument
and i have found
as a consequence let's say of a baptism
by fire that that's not a good way to
approach like one of the things i really
wanted to do with you i hope we managed
this today was
to to ask you questions and find out
more about what you thought like in a
real genuine manner not only in any of
that none of that the last time i talked
to sam all i did was ask him questions
and we had by far the best discussion
we've ever had okay and so he
through that discussion i was alerted
to
reasons why he was so anti-pathetic to
the idea of religion okay and so i
thought i would
so sam is very obsessed with the idea of
totalitarian atrocity
i would say evil fundamentally if you
wanted to make it metaphysical
but you could say
restrictive dogmatic tribalism of the
sort that makes us demonize and destroy
people ideas
o'clock but so what did you want to ask
me because we
we have our night of time i
i want to ask you
when you
talk about religion yes
do you identify the religious impulse
let's say or even the religious
phenomena
with the totalitarian proclivity for
dogmatic certainty and the potential
acceleration of
aggression and atrocity as a consequence
no
um i have
i care first and foremost about
scientific truth and so to me it is an
it is a scientific question
whether there is a supernatural power
creative power intelligence in the
universe i think that's a very
fascinating question i think that if
that were true
it would be the most important
scientific truth if there is that would
be it would be a fundamentally different
kind of universe that we live in if
there is a creative intelligence
so although i have a secondary interest
in negative consequences of religion and
so on especially in islam
um i i my my fundamental interest is in
the
scientific truth which i believe is a
scientific question even if it can't be
answered by scientific means it
that there either is a god or there
isn't and that that either is a creator
or not at the base of the universe
an intelligence i think there's not i
think that intelligence is something
that comes late into the universe as a
consequence of a long evolutionary
process it happened here it no doubt
happened what probably happened in other
parts of the universe
and do you distinguish between
intelligence and consciousness
uh
for this purpose no okay for this
purpose no okay so
let me ask you this question and
do you think that sexual selection is
mediated by consciousness slash
intelligence
uh
in those species that have consciousness
yes
i mean then i would ask you
to what degree do you think that
consciousness
operates as a
fundamental mechanism of selection and
shaping
because that's that
i mean that that is a very profoundly
interesting question and and i mean
sexual selection happens in insects
which i do not think are conscious so so
um yeah well that's a tough one i mean i
know butterflies can detect a deviation
from symmetry and they're part of the
part of one in a million so
yes there's there's
sexual selection throughout the animal
kingdom
um and consciousness can happen without
consciousness i think so yes but but
let's let's look in humans yes yes i
think so okay so okay so when i look at
the
religious epistemology cross-culturally
i see
a bipartite structure at the bottom of
the hypothesizing
there's an idea that there's a material
substrate that consists of a kind of
latent potential that might be one way
of looking at it and that there's the
action of a forming
process on top of that
and
it looks to me like it's something like
what would you call it an intuitive
apprehension of the relationship between
consciousness and the rise to complexity
of living forms
and the reason that i'm curious about
that from an evolutionary perspective is
that
i can't see how sex forget about
unconscious sexual selection for a
minute we'll just parse that off because
maybe they're gradations of
consciousness i don't know insects do
some damn complex things and have you
ever seen that bbc clip of the puffer
fish making a sculpture
oh yes i think yes yes i mean yes that's
quite something because that puffer fish
is we should talk on the way to the chat
we can do that okay okay
well
it's very it's hard day to talk to you
to penrose and you in the same day i
know yes um um
so so
i don't think it's completely out of the
realm of question that part of the
apprehension that there's a spirit that
gives rise to material order is a
metaphysical reflection of the idea that
consciousness shapes biological being
through sexual selection but that spirit
would have to have been around before
evolution got started and so well that
okay look fair enough big thing
that's a yes that's a big problem but
then
i guess a rejoinder to that in some
sense would be
do you think it's a nonsensical
proposition to
i mean one of the things i was talking
to dr penrose today about was
he believes that consciousness in some
sense stands outside the domain of
algorithmic computation i know he does
yes and we discussed in some detail
why he believes that and i'm very
curious about that my brother-in-law
is probably the world's foremost
computer chip designer okay and he's
currently designing a chip
that he thinks will have the
computational power of a human brain
and he was the first person to build a
64-bit chip and he did that in 1985 okay
and so we've had a lot of discussions
about
the limits of ai so this is an ai
optimized chip by the yes
my brother-in-law
thinks that
computation is algorithmic and so it's
comp or that that that thought is
computational yeah and algorithmic and
that can be replicated in ai systems
yeah
penrose thinks that
goodell's theorem precludes that that
there has to be something standing
outside yeah now i tried to push him on
what he regarded as the metaphysical
significance of consciousness yes and
he's a very careful thinker he's a lot
like you except he he's more association
in his thinking i would say and he he
thinks it images he does fundamentally
do you think in words uh yes yes and i i
think in words mostly but yes
but images have quite a hold on me as
well as you as you pointed out
do you think that the proposition that
consciousness is implicit in matter
is a useful and non-nonsensical
statement i think it's nonsensical and i
don't think that's what roger said no i
know i know i it isn't yeah no it isn't
he didn't say that
but
i suppose it depends to some degree on
what you mean by implicit right but
obviously matter can give rise to
consciousness
with sufficient complexity
yes
but not i mean
you people are saying like every you
know consciousness even in stones yes i
know i know i've talked about psychotic
well it just strikes me that it doesn't
really help answer the question yes so
hello hello
i think very well you both you need to
take our microphone